[Applaudissements]
tout avait pourtant bien commencé
corne de brume drapeau tricolore maillot
de l'équipe de France au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
les supporters ont répondu présent
on va dire l'Argentine mes mots mon cœur
est français et voilà je suis française
vive la France mais l'Argentine a quand
même mené une très belle coupe du monde
et pour y avoir été il mérite à une de
gagner une petite coupe du monde là près
de 6000 supporters français
remplissaient les gradins et la fausse
du Vélodrome national mais lors de la
première période ce sont les quelques
supporters argentins présents qui font
la fête l'Argentine même deux à zéro
content pour l'Argentine pour Messi pour
du Maria parce que j'ai soutenu la
journée depuis 2006 et 2022 c'est pour
pour Messi et pour la Gentine en équipe
de France elle est en dessous
on n'a pas on n'a pas tiré on n'a pas
cadré et la gentille n'est plus
agressive
de zéro c'est difficile on y croit quand
même c'est pas fini il y a il faudra un
petit sursaut la seconde mi-temps pour
que on puisse marquer déjà au moins un
premier but et après espérer au moins
d'utilisation et ce sursaut a bien eu
lieu la France égalise grâce à Kylian
Mbappe et pousse les Argentins à la
prolongation
[Applaudissements]
30 minutes de plus ou aucune des deux
équipes n'arrive à faire la différence
3 3 direction une insoutenable séance de
tir au but où les Argentins remportent
finalement la coupe franchement je suis
très très déçu moi je m'attendais à une
victoire sur c'était un match compliqué
mais on assure rattraper mais que ça se
termine comme ça c'est
vraiment pas les mouches vraiment
dégoûté totalement dégoûté ce match
c'était un c'était que des un ascenseur
émotionnel
de la joie de la bonne humeur qu'on
passe de la tristesse comme ça d'un coup
franchement je suis j'ai rien à dire
ascenseur émotionnel pour certains une
revanche pour d'autres la finale de la
Coupe du monde aura fait vibril et fans
de football et restera gravée dans les
mémoires
et pourquoi pas se donner rendez-vous
dans quatre ans au vélo de route